hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about collagen and the types of
collagen there's actually over 28
different types of collagen we're not
going to cover all of them I'm gonna
cover five of them okay now what is
collagen it's the type of protein and
it's the connective tissue it comes from
the Greek word which means glue because
it holds everything together as a mesh
as a like a matrix of strands okay so
number one the type one is the most
abundant 90% of all of the collagen is
this type and it forms scar tissue it
forms the tendons the ligaments the bone
is made out of collagen with minerals to
make it solid the teeth are also a lot
of collagen in there certain parts and
calcium and then we have skin in
arteries okay that's type 1 tattoo is
all the joint cartilage and their
articular surfaces that connect on that
joint so if you were to have a joint
that's wore out you would want to
probably take more of the two versus
maybe weak ligaments that's a whole
different thing okay Type three is the
connective tissue the collagen that is
like the mesh around the liver inside
the liver that separates the different
things it's more delicate it's in the
bone marrow it's in the lymph okay
that's three okay four forms the
respiratory tract and that's involved in
the bronchial tubes the lungs the around
the intestines the tissue around the
heart the tissue around the intestines
okay that's type 4 and then type 5 forms
the hair and the cell surfaces okay
those are the different types so anytime
you're buying collagen there's different
types you can you can buy it from
different sources sometimes collagen
comes from chicken sternum sometimes it
comes from bone marrow sometimes it
comes from fish skin sometimes it comes
from pig skin so it comes from many
different sources now the question is is
it just a matter of consuming collagen
to put the collagen back
not necessarily there's a couple really
important things you need to know if
your vitamin C deficient you will not be
able to metabolize collagen collagen
will not form in the body - Ella you're
gonna have weakness within the ligaments
the cartilage and just if you take a
look at a vitamin C deficiency called
scurvy for example what's happening they
have a lot of collagen loss they have
bleeding gums their teeth are falling
out what is that well what happens
vitamin C is necessary to form the
collagen very very tightly it's because
if you don't vitamin C it can leak blood
and that's called micro hemorrhaging
it's the same exact thing that people
have in their arteries so if they have
like a clogged artery for example the
first thing that happens is a micro
hemorrhage hemorrhaging so you have the
bleeding the cholesterol comes the
calcium comes forms a plaque that's
because they have a small version of
scurvy in the arteries so what happens
is if you gave them type 1 collagen it
might not work what they need is the
vitamin C so vitamin C is very important
and with collagen make sure that you get
a natural version if you're using some
synthetic it better come with a lot of
flavonoids or other factors okay number
2 gastric bypass if you have a gastric
bypass what's happening is you're not
going to be able to digest the collagen
as well because your stomach is not as
big and it's altered the physiology is
altered so you might have loose skin
it's hard to get the skin back lastly is
low stomach acids if you don't have
enough stomach acid you can't digest the
collagen so you can't even pull it in to
break down the collagen that is going
through your mouth whether its food or
supplement it's not breaking down at the
stomach level so it never gets broken
down to the small particles now how do
you know if you have low stomach acids
well you're gonna have gas maybe an iron
deficiency b12 deficiency indigestion
acid reflux and that could be a clue
that you need more stomach acid and all
of a sudden the collagen that you're
consuming from your food is working ok
so just want to kind of give you some
insights and
call it different collagen types and it
might not be a matter of just consuming
collagen you might have to look at these
other factors alright thanks for
watching